[Music]
everybody is talking about Miley Cyrus's
controversial new video wrecking ball
okay it has already over 100 million
views on YouTube I think it smashed
every record now there's apparently a
new controversy it turns out Miley Cyrus
might have stolen the idea for the video
yes we tracked down an obscure local ad
from the Chicago area that is
suspiciously similar and it was made
over two years ago I think Miley has to
answer a lot of questions once this gets
out take a look hi I'm Cal Taupin from
tap and appliance where we're knocking
down prices all this month
top quality refrigerators microwaves and
air conditioners only top and appliance
takes a sledgehammer the high interest
rate
why am I dressed like this because I'm
crazy about bargains for a limited time
by any front load washing machine and
get the grinder for fridge so swing on
by we've got ten convenient locations
our prices are so low they'll make you
dizzy
we're licking the competition
[Applause]
right where it's always a party in the
US
[Applause]